(ambient music)
- [Voiceover] In former
times, Europe used to have
large mammals like the European
wild horse, the auroch,
and also the European bison.
We lost the European wild
horse, we lost the auroch.
Both got extinct.
And we nearly lost the European bison.
Rewilding Europe is a new
conservation initiative
in Europe, trying to make
Europe a wilder place.
The bison plays a very important role.
We say it is a keystone
species in European landscapes.
Because of its grazing
and browsing behavior,
it has an impact on the
vegetation and the landscape,
and that brings new species
in the system, in fact.
(contemplative music)
We're here in Armenis in Romania.
These bison that have
been brought here today
have traveled a few
thousand kilometers by road.
People from the local community,
from the municipality, the mayor is here.
There's a whole community
around Armenis, which, of course,
is very interested and also excited
about this initiative.
The animals get out of the truck,
they don't run away,
they just hang around.
They put their horns in the ground,
and they start fighting with each other.
It's their way of trying
to get used to a place.
We release them in small groups
into a small area, then we
release them into the wild.
(ambient piano music)
Everybody knows Europe having
fantastic cultural heritage,
but we also have a
beautiful natural heritage.
It's amazing to see how nature responds,
and how species come back.
It would be a tragedy if we
would lose another big mammal.
What we hope, of course,
as Rewilding Europe,
is that large herds of bison
can roam our landscapes again,
and people can enjoy it.